welcome back so in the last few videos
we've been talking about balance
truncation and balance proper orthogonal
decomposition which scales to very large
systems and here we're going to code up
an example so this is MIMO balance
truncation example MIMO just means I
have a system with multiple inputs
multiple outputs MIMO okay so we're
gonna clear everything we're gonna build
a system that has two inputs to outputs
and a state dimension of a hundred okay
so you could do bigger but hundreds
enough for our purposes in MATLAB
there's this great built-in command
called D RSS discrete random state space
system that allows me to get a system
that has order n state P outputs and Q
inputs so this is a hundred dimensional
state two inputs and two outputs in
system full because this is a live demo
i pre generated one that looks kind of
nice and I saved it in test system so
I'm just gonna load that one but you can
try this with different random state
space systems and see what happens in
different cases and then what I'm doing
is I'm choosing a rank my truncated rank
of my system is going to be articles ten
so in this example we're gonna use
balance truncation and balance p OD to
reduce the rank of my system to get a
reduced order model from order 100 down
to order ten and we're gonna see how
good that that order ten model is at
capturing the fold dynamics okay so I'm
gonna run this good now when I whenever
I look at a system especially you know I
generate a random state space system I
always plot I always plot the Hankel
singular values of that system to see
how aggressively I can truncate so in
this case it's very simple in MATLAB to
get these you just do HS s HS VD Hankel
singular value decomposition of my full
system I'm going to only save the vector
of singular values and I'm gonna plot
them on a log scale
okay good so I hope you can see this
what we have is on a log scale to Hankel
singular values versus the model order
and this is the cumulative sum of those
Henkel singular values so I literally
just add all of these up and it should
go from zero to one and so what you can
see here this is not a log scale so this
is a little hard to interpret this is 16
orders of magnitude on the log scale
that's huge okay
and so even though it looks like there's
this slow decay if you look over here on
the cumulative sum plot you can see that
the first ten modes capture like over
90% of the Henkel singular value energy
okay so over 90% of the energy is
captured in those first ten modes given
by this red dot here so that's a good
sanity check for me which means I can
probably get a pretty good input-output
model that captures most of the most
important behavior with a rank 10 model
okay
now for a hundred dimensional system I
can just use straight-up balance
truncation if I was in a much larger
setting I'd have to do balanced p OD so
I'm going to show you how to do both in
the code okay the thing I love about
MATLAB is that exact balance truncation
is one line in MATLAB okay so ball read
balanced reduction of my system at rank
R and it just spits out a reduced order
model a rank R model ABCD matrices in
this system using balance truncation
this is built-in it's wrapped around
super efficient Fortran code so this is
great
one-line MATLAB command now if we had a
bigger system we'd actually have to do
balance proper orthogonal decomposition
which is a lot more involved it's not
one line it's tens of lines okay and I
have it in this code here I might just
very briefly walk through but you can
read all of the code and I also have a
dedicated function called BPO diem which
takes my full system my adjoint system
and rank R and returns a balanced model
of rank R okay so you can use this code
for big systems you can read through it
you can figure out you can basically
verify that this is doing all of the
steps of maths that I showed you in the
previous lectures okay
so what do you do you take an impulse
response of your full-system
okay you take an impulse you have to
compute the adjoint system so this is my
adjoint system and then you have to take
an impulse response of your adjoint
system so these give me big data
matrices x full and X adjoint are these
kind of curly c and curly o matrices of
my direct and adjoint snapshots in time
okay we run those from these impulse
response simulations this is so much
easier in MATLAB than it would be to
code up your own simulation because
these impulse responses in a real system
you'd actually have to simulate that
system okay so this is this is easier
for linear state-space systems okay then
I basically this is some fancy in MATLAB
to build that Hankel matrix C times Oh
curly C times sorry curly o times curly
see is this Hankel matrix and then I
take the singular value decomposition I
pull out the relevant pieces I build my
direct and adjoint modes Phi and sy and
finally last step is I project my
dynamics my big a B and C dynamics down
onto these reduced a B and C dynamics
just like I showed you in the lectures
with math okay and my balanced model is
that rank our model okay you don't have
to understand everything that's going on
but what you should know is I should
probably run these codes you can compute
your balance truncation super
efficiently one-line MATLAB if it's a
small enough system if it's a much
larger system you're gonna have to do
BPO D so I'm gonna run that code this
might take a little while because it's
running all these impulse responses and
now what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
plot the impulse responses for all of
the methods okay it's evaluating it
takes a little bit of time to run all
these impulse responses okay so what did
we have we had a multi input multi
output system two inputs to outputs and
so because we had two inputs and two
outputs the impulse response what it
does is it impulsively kicks the first
input
holding the second input equal to zero
and it measures the two outputs and then
it does the same thing it impulsively
kicks the second input while the first
input is zero and it measures those two
outputs so I get this two-by-two array
of impulse responses here now I hope you
can read this the full order model is in
blue the balance truncation model with
rank R is in red and the balanced p OD
model of rank R is in gold okay and so I
hope what you see here is that all of
these curves are following quite closely
so there's some natural dynamics and
some time scales my rank 10 model is
doing an excellent job of capturing the
dynamics of the full hundred dimensional
system if you zoom in you can see there
are some little differences so you know
I could do better with a higher order
model but this is pretty impressive a
rank 10 model is actually capturing
almost all of the input output energy
input to output energy of the system so
my transfer function is gonna be good my
impulse responses look clean and I have
a much more a much smaller more
efficient model to evaluate I can
evaluate this little 10 by 10 model
instead of my big hundred by hundred
model and I can do that faster online
for control okay also nice to see that
balance truncation in balanced p OD
basically give you the same thing okay
they should okay so I guess what I would
try now this is just on the fly we
should probably try to see what happens
if I have a smaller model order maybe
order three or four if we are more
aggressive what's gonna happen so let's
go back all we have to do is change our
to three I'm not sure how this is gonna
work I've never done this live okay I'm
going to again plot my Hankel singular
values and now you see that we're only
capturing 40% of the energy here so
that's not a lot let's see how my system
response looks okay balance truncation
balance P OD and now we're gonna plot
all the methods together really don't
know what's going to happen interesting
okay
okay so what do we notice right off the
bat the blue curves and the red and
orange curves agree much less well and
the gold curves and the and the red
curves also agree less well so the
balance truncation and the balance P o d
do not agree very well if I go too
aggressively on the model reduction and
either of them agree with the full order
model so I really do need you know in
this case more like model order 10 to
get a good model okay so 10 HSV D we
caption anymore like 90% of the energy
let's go back and compute my balance
truncation balance P OD okay and then
we're gonna run these impulse responses
and it's thinking okay so good this is
just a sanity check that if I have
enough model order everything starts
agreeing okay so something I'd like you
to think about and I'm gonna think about
it too is why is it that the balanced p
OD in the balance truncation agree well
for enough rank for rank 10 where i get
a good system response why don't they
agree for rank 3 why is it the BPO d
starts to fail an approximating balance
truncation if i overly aggressively
truncate the rank that would be
something interesting to think about in
terms of kind of the equations we wrote
down earlier and the matrices and
that'll give you a lot of intuition for
for what this connection is so if you
can work that out you're a master of
balance truncation and balance proper
orthogonal decomposition okay useful
technique if you have the equations of
motion if you have a B and C you have a
simulation that can run them but they're
big you can use balance truncation and
balance PID to get a reduced order
system that's much more tractable fast
to run fast to design and implement
controllers on and pretty accurate okay
so in the next few lectures we're going
to talk about what happens if I don't
have a simulation that was this was
model reduction I had the model what
happens if I don't have the model and
all I have is measurement data like this
all I have in these blue curves how
would I build a model that's system
identification it's based
the exact same mathematical framework of
balanced grampians and all of this stuff
Hankel matrices but procedurally it only
assumes that you have experimental data
so this is something you can actually do
from real experiments that's what we're
going to talk about next time
that's the eigen system realization
algorithm thank you